adult social care is often disk from
tanned back door to the NHS and he
didn't Liverpool the demands and the
service are rapidly increasing people
are able to leave hospital so much more
quickly than before
yeah that doesn't necessarily mean
they're ready to go home I imagine you
pretty busy here on a daily basis
yeah especially over the winter months
when people fall more often there's more
hip you know people break the hip more
often make them into hospital they may
have an operation which magically fixes
the hip but then they need support and
lineage reagent in order to get back on
the feet again and that's where we come
into the physiotherapist will work with
people they will set exercise as our
staff will then do those exercises with
people on a daily basis if they were at
home that wouldn't happen people would
be at risk of not gaining that mobility
back and they'd be at risk of having
fear the Falls and ending up back in
hospital father Tony hunts worked in
Africa for the Catholic Church for
almost 50 years but a series of heart
attacks and other health issues mental
returned home to Liverpool for treatment
now he's part at work hoping to soon be
back with his friends and able to return
to some degree of normalcy the next toe
did probably have to cook maybe all the
toes off or it could still grow and it
go into the foot and then they might
still grow and come up to the buff the
knee so they said we don't think you can
take three major operations because of
him we had been told wasn't to have any
more general anesthetics because of the
we caught
so they decided they had to cut it off
here so they suggest about two weeks ago
now I was a rapidly aging population
placing more strain on the budgets and
the individual cost of these services
Rises and excellent it's easy to be
despondent about the future yet despite
losing his leg father Tony remains
positive thanks in part to a little help
from his friend
Oh today I've got my faith you know I've
got a great belief in God and I actually
said today doctor the surgeon who was
talking about cutting the leg off so why
say we'll listen don't worry doctor it's
a win-win situation I said if you cut it
off and it's successful and it helps me
to get better well you wanna see I says
but if you try to cut it off and it
fails that I went because I go to heaven
[Laughter]
yet despite their prayers local
authorities across the country have seen
significant cuts to their budgets which
has had the effect of closer integration
with the Health Service to avoid the
duplication of costs but serves to
remind that while the NHS has its
funding protected councils are being
asked to raise council tax to try and
plug the gap Liverpool says it will
always protect the most vulnerable but
argue that means not everyone will
continue to receive those services
council tax is a highly regressive tax
so it raises more proportionate money
from poorer people than say income tax
ties or corporation tax and also the
areas of the country that have the
greatest amount of social need areas of
ill health lots of declining
manufacturing industries for example
errors like Liverpool or big northern
cities they have very low property
prices they have very low capacity to
raise council tax whereas if you go if
you took the same properties down to
Surrey their values would be much
greater you would raise from a percent
the same percentage increase are a lot
more money in the wealthy areas
council tax raises the biggest amount of
money in the area of least need it's a
very ineffective and unfair way of
trying to bridge the funding gap so
what's in a name the Secretary of State
for Health and Social Care would
presumably insist that the change to his
Job Description represents something far
more substantial than a pressing need
for a new brass plaque and scientist
Whitehall office yet the two health care
and social care have traditionally been
distinct one provided by the NHS the
other by local authorities one free at
the point of delivery the other often
involving significant expense it's
difficult to reconcile claims of a
crisis in social care with its many
success stories but as the population
ages patient needs become more complex
costs rise faster than budgets it would
appear a crunch point is approaching do
you think it was government ministers
not responsible for this or are simply
being naive about the effect that these
cuts have had or do you think these
actions are being carried out in full
knowledge ministers simply don't want to
face the reality of this crisis at once
they admit there's a crisis they have to
do something about it that means
providing more funding and looking again
at how health and social services work
together that are running away from the
challenge other than meeting it it's
difficult to believe but more people
work in social care at than in the
health service and yet only one has its
funding ring-fenced the government has
made much of its efforts to secure
parity of esteem for physical and mental
health given its role in relieving the
burden on the NHS is it too much to ask
to place social care and health care on
a similarly equal footing